no your eyes do not deceive you that's
Shawn Mendes and Camilla Kibeho giving
us PDA level 100 if there was any doubt
before Camilla definitely knows how
Shawn tastes and we're still feeling
pretty weird about it it all went down
Wednesday night
Camilla dropped her music video for liar
and about an hour later Shawn dropped a
little video of his own on Instagram cue
the makeout sesh of all make-out
sessions we saw like on Twitter and
stuff you guys saying stuff about the
way we're kissing and out looks weird
like we kissing fish yeah and really
hurting our feelings we just actually
have a case yeah but also let's watch
that one more time and the reactions
were everything with a lot of what's pus
and Shooks left in the comments
tanomo joe said that the kiss is
ingrained in my brain forever charlie
puth and Julia Michaels just laughed
bazi said Shawn Milla had incredible
form Mark Ballas said he was dead and
Nikita dragon wrote I think this video
got me pregnant me too Camilla recently
opened up about her and Sean's public
displays of tonsil hockey during a
sit-down with Sirius XM Radio's hits one
where she responded to a headline that
said they kissed like two characters in
a rom-com I think a beard smooching you
got it smooth like you're in a rom-com I
love that you want to smooch but you're
in a boring drama yeah preach and
Camilla brought all the drama from her
telenovela inspired music video for liar
[Music]
in the video the 22 year olds is stuck
in a hilarious nightmare loop where we
see her get smashed by an elephant run
over by cyclist and attacked by a swarm
of drones totally normal no big deal
anywho Camilla had teased the music
video on Instagram writing in the
caption that it was the quote most fun
video she had ever worked on um more fun
than seniorita Camilla
[Music]
yeah maybe not Camila released liar as
well as shameless and its accompanying
music video last week before that the
former fifth harmony member declared a
new era of music with this dreamy clip
that read welcome to the world of
romance in a statement Camila explained
the meaning behind her second solo album
quotes these songs are basically the
story of my life the past couple years
and the stories I've accumulated I knew
for a long time I wanted my album to be
called romance because these stories are
all about falling in love and during her
sit-down with hits one she echoed that
sentiment my songs have always been
personal like even the last album
because I'm writing them so they're my
stories but I think that it's just a lot
more detail because I'm living a lot
more yeah and by living I think she
means smooching whatever it is that's
inspiring these bangers keep on doing it
Camila of course ET will be right here
to keep you in the loop on all things
Camila and Shawn so make sure to keep it
locked or right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]